- Have you always loved Broadway
'cause your new album
- Always.
- is all Broadway?
- I grew up,
it's all Broadway
and I've always wanted to do this record.
- Yeah.
- It for me
it has been the most
and I know you've had
these kinds of records
that feel the most vocally exciting
- Yeah.
- and the most
vocally expansive, especially
because as artists,
sometimes if we get pegged with one sound.
- 100%, that's why I
love Christmas albums,
you can do whatever there.
- Yeah, me too,
you could do whatever you
want and nobody says anything.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay, nobody cries, nobody
fusses, nobody whines.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Exactly.
- Just sounds classic, yeah.
- So I've always wanted to do this
'cause I grew up doing theater.
- Yeah.
- I grew up, you know,
in community theater and
high school and college
all throughout and always
really wanted to get back to it.
Super thankful for the
success I had as a musician,
- Yeah.
- but also thankful
that that success has let me enter into
then the theater community at a place
- Yeah.
- 'cause you came and saw me,
years ago, like
- Yes, I did.
- in Chicago.
- And you were
freaking awesome
and I've always wanted to,
I'm a nerd for Broadway too,
I grew up with
- I know you are!
- musical theater
and so I am envious of this whole project
and I was envious and just
so elated for you as well.
- Thank you.
- You shine so bright.
- Yeah, you get it though.
- It was so good.
- It's like it, it holds
a place in your heart
and it really I think informs--
- It's a hard thing to do too,
Broadway is hard
- Yeah.
- like it's a big schedule.
- It's an, yes it is--
- If you can nail that
you're amazing.
- It's a big schedule.
- Yeah.
- But it's just so
enriching and so worth it
and I think, you know, the music itself
just as you're saying is,
it's so informative as an artist
and I know you get this
too as a performer,
you know you learn about what it is
to be a character in a song,
you learn about what it is to embody that.
- It's not that far from country to me.
- It's all storytelling.
- Like country music
is all storytelling.
- It's all storytelling.
- Yeah.
That's why when everybody, yeah they said
you were doing the album.
- For sure.
I was like, well it's
like more storytelling.
- Obviously.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Not a big leap.
- Yeah.